On Conflict Zone this week: Ethiopia's
Civil War, now more than a year old and
showing no sign of ending. All sides
are accused of unspeakable atrocities.
Zadig Abraha is the Minister for Democratization
and he joins me from the capital Addis Ababa.
What we want is peace. We have
been trying to secure peace.
It turns out your troops have committed
just as many war crimes as the other side.
Are they ordered to do that or are
they out of control? Which is it?
No, we aim at holding our troops
to heighten their standards.
The country's Prime Minister, Abiy Ahmed, won
a Nobel Prize for making peace with neighboring
Eritrea. This time, he's promised to bury
his enemies in the northern region of Tigray.
While they fight more than two
million people have been displaced
and thousands face famine.
Will Ethiopia's government
stop the mass detention of Tigrayans? Will
it end the humanitarian blockade on Tigray?
And how does the government justify its crackdown
on the media? All that and more on Conflict Zone.
Zadig Abraha, welcome to Conflict Zone.
Good to see you Tim, same here.
Your government has promised to hold accountable
any of your forces that violated human rights,
especially those who committed acts of rape.
How many of your soldiers have been
tried and sentenced for these violations?
I cannot come up with a specific number because it
is an ongoing issue. The investigation has not yet
stopped and since we have an ongoing conflict...
Well, has it started? You say it hasn't stopped,
has it started?
Yes, it has.
So people have been sentenced, have they?
It is — a number of people have been brought
to a court of law, so the sentence has yet
to happen, but still the investigation is an
ongoing one. More people, we believe more and
more people will be answerable to this process.
So nobody has been sentenced so
far, is what you're telling me.
No, what I'm saying and what I'm
telling you is it's up to the courts.
The government has committed itself and has
organized the committee overseeing this process.
And the government has also exposed itself
to scrutiny of comprising the UNHCR, the UN
Human Rights Commission. So when it comes to...
I understand, I wasn't asking you about the
process. I was asking you about
the result, whether anybody has
actually been sentenced so far.
I do not have a specific number now.
I'm not going. Has anybody been sentenced? I
don't even need the number. Has anybody been
sentenced so far?
Yes.
And are we talking about five,
10, 50? Roughly how many?
I cannot come up with a specific number.
And can you tell me what the range of
penalties has been so far?
Still, I don't have a number.
I don't have a specific information as to
that, but it is important, that we started...
This isn't a very transparent
process, is it Mr Abraha?
Is it a very transparent process.
Well, it isn't if you can't even tell me how many
people have been arrested, detained, prosecuted...
It doesn't mean ... I don't have a number now,
but it doesn't mean this is not a transparent
process. We have shown our commitment and
transparency to accountability, by subjecting
ourselves to a huge scrutiny. So I don't think
transparency is an issue here. It's just a
matter of information, and I don't have it now.
Well, it is, according to the Office
of the Human Rights Commissioner.
She flagged up considerable concerns about your
judicial processes. She said, disturbingly,
that your court proceedings lacked transparency
and did not meet international standards.
What's your excuse for that? You told me
there's transparency, she says there isn't any.
We have introduced a series of reforms
with a view to making our courts
up the international standard, to making them
transparent ones. And we have a gained, we have
gone a number of steps when it comes to that. So
I think one of the things where we can proudly say
when it comes to our judicial processes
for the past three and a half years we
have introduced a number of reforms and
these reforms have yielded transparency
and accountability. And if you were here to see
it in person, I am sure you wouldn't say that.
Why don't — Why don't these trials take place
in public with the press free to report on them?
You know, some of these things are, can only
be presided by the courts, the military courts
and when it's, if it happens to be civilians,
it has to be seen by a, by a civilian court. But
we have no problem with making it transparent.
It's a matter of I never heard the
media having an interest in these things.
The media are very interested because it's
not only important that justice is done, justice
has to be seen to be done as well, doesn't it.
This government has shown a high level of
commitment to transparency and accountability
time and again, and making it transparent
to a media, it's up to the courts.
A joint report by the UN Human Rights Office
and Ethiopia's Human Rights Commission
was released last month. It turns out your
troops have committed just as many war crimes
as the other side. Are they ordered to do
that or are they out of control? Which is it?
No, we aim at holding our troops to
high ethical standards. And you know,
you have the number of reservations
with regard to the outcome of this…
You accepted the report. You accepted the report.
Yeah, but we have reservations about it.
We have not only accepted this outcome, we
have started implementing the recommendations
indicated by the joint investigation, by
establishing a joint ministerial committee.
So our army, when you talk of our army we
believe, it exhibits, largely exhibited,
ethics and discipline. But there are some
outlets that are, that are gone out of the,
that have committed other various acts or these
things, atrocities indicated in the report.
And we are committed to make sure that these
individuals are brought to a court of law and
get their sentences as per the law of the nation.
Not only have atrocities been committed minister,
but Michelle Bachelet, the UN chief human rights
officer, says it appears your forces, along with
those of Eritrea, committed the majority of
the violations for the first eight months
of the conflict between November 2020 and
June this year. That's a hugely damaging
observation for your government, isn't it?
It is regrettable that these atrocities happened.
We have differences when it comes to the number
of atrocities committed and who committed it.
But with all that, we don't want to debate on the
amount and the intensity of the forces. Whatever
atrocities may have happened on one person, on
two persons, it doesn't matter. We don't want to
tolerate it. We have zero tolerance to this kind
of atrocities. But if you want to know the larger
picture of our army, our army has been throughout
a number of African countries, it is an example
of discipline and effectiveness, and that does
not represent the larger picture of our army.
But these are individuals that are being brought
to a court of law. And we will continue to do so.
You, you say your army adheres to, to high
standards, but there are a remarkable variety,
a huge variety of serious crimes listed
as having been committed by your forces,
attacks against civilians and indiscriminate
attacks, for instance. November 28 last year,
the report says, your army shelled civilian
facilities in Mekelle, killing at least 29
people and injuring 34. Doesn't that shock you?
I said it's very regrettable and we don't tolerate
this kind of action, these kind of violations.
But it doesn't change the fact that our army
has been chosen to be a member of the UN peace
keeping mission throughout Africa. And it is not
without a reason. It's because of its exhibit
of discipline and ethics that it was chosen
to be to oversee this kind of missions. But
still in Tigray, where our army was in Tigray,
the larger picture, the bigger picture is, our
army has been supplying the people with food, with
fuel ... our army has been apportioning from...
And I want to
I want to come on to the question of aid a bit
later. But before we leave these crimes, one
of the categories highlighted by the report
was sexual and gender-based violence. And
the report says your army, along with
other forces, was implicated in multiple
reports of gang rape used to degrade and
dehumanize victims. So these crimes — multiple,
multiple reports of gang rape. These crimes
aren't just the work of a few rogue soldiers, are
they, as some of your colleagues have suggested?
They're systematic, they're practiced, and
they're repetitive. I wonder what would lead your
troops to think those violations are acceptable?
There is no way. For one thing, I have said that
we have accepted this report with reservations.
And there is no way for any kind of
rape to be systematic here in Ethiopia.
Tigrayian people are our people. Our army was
there to liberate Tigrayan people from the yoke of
the TPLF, from the authoritarian hold of the TPLF.
And there is no way for this to be systematic. It
is only the act of individuals within the army and
we are making sure that these people are punished
for their criminal deeds. It does not explain...
It does not represent the act of our army. No
one can possibly say that this is systematic. Our
system, our, — if you want — if it was systematic,
there was, there was no possibility for this
people to be brought in the court of law.
We now know, Minister, we now know, Minister,
that terrible crimes were also committed by your
allies from Eritrea. You told this program last
December that you were a thousand percent sure
that there were no Eritrean troops in your
country. In fact, they'd been there since
last November, according to a Reuters special
investigation. Why? Why didn't you mention that?
I said, I talked the Eritrean army right
now, underline right now. And for second,
you know, we might have differences …
But the interview was in December and the Eritrean
troops were there in November, months before.
You know, when it comes to transparency,
when the day, when the time came, when,
when we believe when our intel showed
the Eritrean army was there, the prime minister
has come up to the parliament and talked about
it. And then, you know, we may have differences
on intel. Your information may show you September,
mine was right before, after December. That's
why. It was not said out of an intention to
mislead international community. It was said
based on the information we have on the ground.
But it wasn't until March that Prime Minister
Abiy revealed that Eritrean forces had entered
Ethiopia, he said, to support him. Up until then,
your government was dismissing all the reports as
hostile propaganda. And in April, your Information
Minister Yemane Gebremeskel said the reports
about Eritrean troops raping Tigrayan women
were simply fabricated stories, fabricated
by the party in power in Tigray, the Tigrayan
People's Liberation Front. That was nonsense.
The stories were not fabricated. They did rape
people and they raped a lot of women, didn't they?
Well, I think the right person... I'm here
to say, when the information we had on the
ground was confirmed, we have come up
in public and talked about it. While
we lacked information and we come, appeared
on Conflict Zone and came up with and said,
talked about my take of the situation. That's all.
In May, your attorney general admitted that your
Eritrean friends had executed 110 civilians
in cold blood in a place called Aksum.
What do you think of your Eritrean friends now?
You know, following the reform introduced
in the country, we have come
up with the following points
that mainly gives priority to our neighbors.
That has changed the situation. Ethiopian...
110 civilians murdered in cold
blood. Are these people going
to be held responsible by your government?
Yes, you know, we have a good relation with
Eritrea. We believe the Eritrean government
will also be part of this effort to bring
these people to justice, and we are not here…
You are going to prosecute Eritrean soldiers,
are you? Are you telling me now your government
intends to prosecute Eritrean soldiers.
As we have indicated, whatever
atrocities committed by whoever,
it will be prosecuted. Where it, who... where …
Eritrea, Ethiopia or is it anywhere different,
that's another story. What I can confirm you - no
kind of human rights violations will be tolerated.
Are Eritrean forces still in Ethiopia?
Your prime minister said in March that
he'd got an agreement for them to leave,
but they haven't left yet, have they?
They have left the country.
When did they leave?
Well that specific time and day has...
Can you give me a month? Can you can you say
whether it was a month ago, three months ago ...
I don't want to be that specific, but I can assure
you that Eritrean forces have left the country.
And you say that with the same kind of
authority as you said, when a year ago,
when you said they weren't in the country?
Well, based on the information I had on my hand,
I have told you that now is the
information, we have intel we have
on our hand shows that and I am here to tell you.
Mr. Minister, part of the reason for a lack
of transparency in Ethiopia these
days is your crackdown on the press,
which is something that you vehemently denied
on this program a year ago. Your denials haven't
held up very well, have they? The Committee to
Protect Journalists said a week ago that since
the start of the war, they've documented multiple
violations of press freedom by your government.
We have got rid of a draconian press law and
came up with a new progressive press law. We have
introduced, we have the, following this reform,
the press freedom in Ethiopia has increased in
both in terms of numbers and quality. I'm telling
you, it's something that speaks for itself.
On December the 1st, at least 9 reporters
were in custody. If they've committed crimes,
charge them if they haven't let them go.
Who are these 9 reporters, can you, can you, can -
because as far as my information, you know,
the, the problem is, our definition of
journalism is different. There are some
social media activists that are working towards
hampering a rule of law, trying to cause havoc.
At the end of October, you forced the closure
of the Awlo Media Centre, an online news outlet
that was critical of the prime minister. Before
that, the Committee to Protect Journalists says
media workers were arrested in late June and
detained incommunicado for several weeks at
a military camp in the east of the country.
You detain these people incommunicado. This is
mafia-style thuggery by your government, isn't it?
Let me tell you, there are journalists that are
committing crime. And if that is the case, we
will continue to make sure that even when it
comes to journalists, their criminal deeds
are punished. But we have, we have seen for
the past four years, we have stopped press
freedom in the cause for journalists to be...
We have, that era is gone. This report has to be
cross-checked. I have to come up. I have to give
the names of specific names, specific information
because you are coming up with a number that is...
I give you, I'll give you specific information
minister. Court orders for the release of two
journalists were given. At least two cases
where court orders were given to release them
from custody. And they weren't released. Kibrom
Worku, a radio journalist and Tesfa-Alem Tekle,
correspondent for Nation Media Group. They
were still in detention earlier this month,
weeks after they were granted bail. Now you
present the picture of a government that
ignores the rulings of its own courts.
That's the lawless country, Minister.
You know, what happened is the public
prosecutor office appealed to the next
level of court and when, when an appeal is
being heard, you cannot free a journalist.
You know, Minster, that you that your own Human
Rights Commission has also expressed grave concern
about the detention of thousands of people
in the capital under your state of emergency
and the difficulty of gathering information
about the treatment of those in detention.
Are they wrong, too? Are they wrong, too?
We are aware of that and we have, we are
working day and night to correct that problem.
You are aware of it? You are in charge,
either you are in charge of the country or not,
you're ordering these detentions. No, it's not.
That is not enough to be aware of them, is it.
No, no. This is a practice of certain police and
we are, we are, we are in charge. We are
correcting these mistakes. The thing is,
we have introduced a state of emergency.
And following that, there are people
who are suspected of committing crimes and they
are under the rule of law that they are being
prosecuted. And in this process that… there are
wrongs here and there and we are correcting them.
You know, the result why, in our own human
rights commission have become stronger.
It is coming up, it is issuing these kind of
reports, which is exposing even our wrongs. This
is a result of the transparency, the result
of accountability measures we have taken.
You've also taken measures against senior
UN officials. You threw out seven of them
in September. You didn't like them telling the
truth. The expulsions were ordered two days after
the UN's aid chief warned that your restrictions
on the flow of aid had probably forced hundreds
of thousands of people in Tigray into famine. Do
you throw out the foreigners now because you don't
like what they're saying about your government?
Not, not at all. We believe in working with
the UN. It is a good partner. We are a
member of the UN. So we have, we will,
we will work with the UN under any circumstances.
But it doesn't mean that these individuals have
… their own code of conduct, their own, their own
bylaws and there were interfering in our internal
issues, but that measure was taken following that.
And the government has explained the reason why we
have taken that measure at that point in time.
The White House in Washington, says that you
have exhibited a pattern of obstructing the
delivery of food, medicine and other lifesaving
supplies to those who are most in need. I
presume you are aware that blocking food and
medical supplies without justification violates
international humanitarian law. Or don't you care?
That's wrong, that's wrong.
That's not what we are doing.
Minister, this war is looking increasingly
unwinnable. Will you negotiate or are you only
interested in outright victory?
You know, we have,
we have a lot to gain in peace, and we
have a lot to lose in the absence of peace.
So what we want is peace. We have been trying
to secure peace, through informal, informal …,
but TPLF gave all these efforts a
deaf ear. That's why we are here.
And, you know, we have to wait a couple of
weeks for these things to unravel themselves.
Minister, the Joint Investigative Report
issued last month, calls on you and the other
combatants to immediately end hostilities
without preconditions and end any measures
that are exacerbating the already acute
humanitarian crisis. Will you do that?
We, on June, we, we declared a unilateral
cease-fire in the … from Tigray. But TPLF said,
it was a sick joke. That's how our, our move for
peace, our initiation for peace, was welcomed.
You know, we have a duty to protect our citizens.
You've all done unspeakably awful things to
each other. How can there be reconciliation now?
We have no problems in reconciliation. We have
no problem with peace. The TPLF has to go back
to where it was. Now it is occupying a number of
cities in Amhara region and committing atrocities.
That has to be stopped. We have a duty to protect
our citizens out there they are crying for help.
Your forces have committed
atrocities as well, let's be honest.
You know, we take seriously
any kind of allegations, we are
looking into that, we have taken a
number of measures to correct that.
But what is TPLF doing? You know, if you happen
to go to a number of cities in Amhara region, you
know, cities are destroyed to ground zero. Women
are raped, farmers are robbed of their yields.
Again, your forces have also been implicated
in rapes. You seem to be very selective,
you seem to be very selective in accusing the TPLF
No, the difference is, when it comes to us. We are
taking these allegations seriously and taking a
number of measures to correct it. We are bringing
these perpetrators to a court of law. We are
ensuring accountability and transparency. But TPLF
is systematically, systematically doing that …
Minister, why did you reject a plan by the UN
Human Rights Council to discuss what it called
the grave human rights situation in your
country, in Geneva on December the 17th?
More than 50-plus countries now called
on discussing the issue. You know,
no African country is party to such move. It
is, and in African countries, discussing about
African issue. And the second thing is we have
accepted the outcome of the Joint Committee
and we have also started to take measures. We
have started to implement the recommendations
by forming inter-ministerial committee. And that’s
nonsense when we have taken these steps. Why?
Why now? And the third thing is, TPLF
is committing a number of violations…
Question is why not? And
what have you got to hide?
… in Amhara region, in Afar region
and this has been given a deaf ear.
This is not, you know, any human rights
violation committed by our forces or TPLF
it has to be taken seriously. It has to be put
on par and investigated without discrimination,
without arrogance. We don't see this happening.
You know, if, if, if there is another, there is
this allegation, committed by our forces
and we see things being … Why do you think
other African countries have joined that move,
apart of that signature. Why do you think?
You tell me.
Because African countries understand that we
have accepted the outcome of the Joint Committee,
the investigation of the Joint Committee. And we
have taken, we have started to take the necessary
measures. Where it is … and at the same time other
African countries are aware of the fact that TPLF
is committing a number of human rights violations
in a number of Amhara cities. And where they see
the situation, it's a double standard. And as
a result they are not part of this signature.
So this is not something where we are the only
country against this move. A number of African
countries are against this move. That's
why they are not part of this initiative.
You've called on everybody to reject this meeting.
Looks like you have something to hide, Minister.
No, it's not. If we had something to hide, we
wouldn't have subjected ourselves to the scrutiny
of the Joint Committee by UNHCR and our own human
rights commission. That wouldn't have happened.
We, you know, we have allowed
them to come on ground and check.
Alright, Minister Zadig Abraha, I am
afraid we're out of time. Thank you
very much for being on Conflict
Zone. Thank you for your time.
Thank you very much.
Same here.
Thank you.